aux côtés des stars de la vente des vins
ou sur le tapis rouge du festival
voilà trente ans qu'un insulino tient le
premier rôle à beaune
c'est ici qu'il s'est construit une
carrière politique retour en 1995 s'il
est déjà élu régional cet avocat de 32
ans remporte alors sa première élection
municipale le projet avec la inscrire
notre ville dans l'an 2000
c'est demain et surtout avoir un projet
de formation pour nos jeunes de création
d'entreprise l'implantation notre 23 ans
et quatre mandats plus tard alain
suguenot occupe toujours le fauteuil de
maire de son fief beaunois il va être
porté à l'assemblée nationale de 2002 à
2010 set s'est joué dans l'hémicycle il
sera un des fervents opposants à la loi
evin décrié le vin comme on le fait en
jetant le bébé avec l'eau du bain sans
doigts de jeu de mot chaque
véritablement s'est joué contre la
france
c'est jouer contre ses intérêts
économiques et ses joues et surtout
contre la morale le vin et le cinéma
deux de ses grands domaines d'action lui
le diplômé en sciences criminelles va
décrocher le festival du film policier
en 2009 et faire venir claude lelouch
pour y installer une école de cinéma
dans la ville sera l'occasion d'avoir un
projet complet pour faire que tous les
passionnés de cinéma viendra bonne site
bonne c'est bien sûr le vin dans l'image
très fort de patrimoine c'est aussi
maintenant ce nouvel univers il estimé
hier soir que les procédures judiciaires
ne lui permettrait pas de participer aux
prochaines échéances politiques
simple coup d'arrêt ou clap de fin
[Musique]